it has been quite some time now since we
last saw anything of note for ubisoft's
upcoming far cry 6
but that has almost certainly wetted the
appetite of fans everywhere even more
thankfully geek culture had the
opportunity to go behind closed doors
and watch a presentation from the team
behind far cry 6.
needless to say everything fans love
about the series is getting more love
attention and upgrades with this new
entry
fake [__] jaren
like other entries of the long-running
franchise far cry 6 drops players into
an environment primed for an explosive
catalyst the island nation of yara is
where we'll find ourselves
up against a dictator and an army ready
to stamp out any resistance
as narrative director naveed kavari puts
it this is an ambitious open world
full of large jungles urban architecture
and plenty of room for fun and
experimentation
players will enter yara 50 years after a
violent revolution a powder keck on the
verge of collapse and you are the match
players will possess the power of agency
aided by the various mechanics at play
in far cry 6 and create the yara of
their dreams
that usually means intense action covert
stealth and set-piece moments of shock
and all representing the game's core dna
perhaps more encouragingly the narrative
and the characters are both looking more
realized as well can leave any time
what's the rush joining up with the
freedom fighters known as the libertad
players step in the shoes of danny rojas
a native born and raised players will
witness the revolution through dany's
eyes right from the beginning
as a former military dropout rohan's aim
was always to get off the island
however the brutality of castillo's
regime threw that aim out of the window
and it is now your job to push forward
and bring him to his bloody knees
to even the odds you would have to count
on some help
clara garcia leads the libertad which is
surprising considering her upper class
heritage
nevertheless she brings a blend of steel
and smarts to the gorilla fighters
and counts on you to unite the people in
this fight
the movement is backed up by gorilla spy
master juan cortes who looks likely to
be the primary source of laughs and
hygiene
despite his charm and laid back nature a
history of revolution betrays a man
hardened by this world
far cry 6 will definitely have more
human companions but we did see the
likes of adorable animal amigos like
guapo the soldier eating crocodile and
chorizo the adorable little puppy that
can melt your heart and bite your head
off
the island of yara is a dangerous place
when it comes to keeping the peace the
army castillo has as his disposal is
your biggest nightmare
checkpoints about the islands give your
enemies the means to control and contain
threats like yourself
while flat cannons ensure that air
superiority is theirs
the addictive outpost gameplay also
makes a welcome return in far cry 6 in
the form of fmd bases
players will be able to look forward to
a variety of locations that has been
taken over by the army and liberating
these locations is key to the fight for
freedom
to get about the island of yara rojas
has some options you could always make
up the distance with the many vehicles
around or take a lesser known route
through gorilla paths
you can bypass military installations
with a network of hidden paths and find
valuable gear to aid you in battle
lastly you can simply hide and play
inside just by holstering your weapons
just remember to keep your distance from
those eager soldiers
in between missions and avengers around
the world players will often return to
the many gorilla camps that have been
set up around yara
hidden away from the enemy's eyes these
act as hub areas where you can pick up
more gear rest up and obtain information
for the missions ahead this will be
extremely important when it comes to the
actual war for yara's freedom
combat and the open world are critical
facets of the farca experience and far
cry 6 is no different ubisoft is looking
to elevate the experience of course
and surprises are lying in wait for
veterans and newcomers alike
far cry 6 is all about realizing the
idea of a one person guerrilla army
gameplay director alex letendre refers
to this as the gorilla fantasy but coded
in the signature far cry pain
this reveals itself in the resolver
philosophy where problems are soft
utilizing resourcefulness and creativity
whatever you can get your hands on can
be turned into something useful in the
battle against the regime
everything in the game for weapons the
vehicles has this consistency built into
it the first time you lay your eyes on a
cd firing contraption playing the
macarena that even skips once you unload
onto the enemy you know exactly what the
developers are going for
resolvable weapons are the true
embodiment of creating chaos with any
means necessary
this can be in the form of a machine gun
powered by a motorcycle engine or a
compressed air nail gun for those silent
kills it is all crazy and all far cry
and there is much to love
as for the more traditional stuff
everything you love about the combat is
likely to be here
the most notable addition through this
design philosophy is that of supremos a
piece of gear that combines the power of
100 gorillas in one neat little package
picking the right supremo for the right
approach will make things much more
manageable for example if you are all
about guns blazing the exterminator will
be right up your alley strapped to the
player's back this diy rocket launcher
will fire off a volley of explosives and
blow up everything in range gear also
becomes much more meaningful in far cry
6. how gear is entirely up to you
accentuating your play style however you
choose your head gear chess gear hand
gear leg gear and foot gear all play a
part
finding the right gear will supplement
how you play
you might be aiming for increased head
shot damage or increased mobility for
the covert approach on the other hand
you can prioritize defense and health if
you like the tank playstyle
the resolver philosophy is also seen on
guerrilla rights you can quickly turn
everyday vehicles into something that
can go up against the might of an army
the customization comes to every aspect
of the vehicles both inside and out
let your creativity and appetite for
destruction show with turrets rams
counter measures and more even better
you can summon your vehicle at almost
every location giving you an option for
a quick getaway or a monstrous weapon at
your disposal
with all of these design tenants in mind
ubisoft is hell bent on delivering
guerrilla warfare far cry style with
this latest entry in the series if the
game can continue where it left off with
two mt18s far cry 5 and go even higher
far cry said
what the [__]
who are they
to defend yara
we will sacrifice in the name of
progress
and we will rebuild paradise